hey I hope it's not sweet I don't like a
sweet like a driver I can try well you
know if it's a screw top it's a lot of
work in between the wrapping the
shopping the cooking the decorating
there's almost no time to actually enjoy
it and only one thing Oh No what does it
could make it even more stressful my
mother's coming for Christmas goddess
legend Sarandon Cheryl Hines ladies and
gentlemen hey Mose best friends Oh
around legend incredible monkey I'm a 34
year old woman and she's still telling
me how to live my life do you remember
how much cookie dough you ate you were
making this up with a cookie dough and
you could stop beating me it's like Mary
I really doubt I would where's my house
yes and 184 people are coming how much
did this cost can you put a price tag on
wonder I just wanted to enjoy Christmas
this year you're a mom mom Stone and joy
they give joy she's gonna keep treating
me like this until you fight her
physically okay both secretly was making
designing a crack den I was just
outlining dead bodies outside of it it's
an up windows yeah raishin somewhat
perfect anything let's put the ass back
in Christmas that didn't come out
exactly as I planned it but you guys go
my favorite scene in the movie duh that
ball waxing oh my god
I had a horrible mother she once slapped
me for wearing open-toed shoes on a
sailboat that was a different time one
it was two months ago guys remember how
much Santa's not like my Manila from
from beyond from yes yes he was so nice
he was so sweet you open your mouth we
went to prom together
oh and then I'm like I'm doing great
well done I'm read we really had a good
eye contact
I didn't make him out none I'm sorry I
can't really cheap too I see that movie